También pueden construir de forma autónoma estructuras tensadas.
Las habilidades aprendidas incluyen llevar cargas,
enfrentar perturbaciones,
y, en general, cómo interactuar con el mundo físico.
Hoy queremos mostrarles algunos nuevos proyectos que hemos trabajado.
Su objetivo es empujar los límites de lo que puede lograrse
con vuelo autónomo.
Para un sistema que funcione de manera autónoma,
debe conocer colectivamente la ubicación de sus objetos móviles en el espacio.
En nuestro laboratorio en ETH Zurich,
a menudo utilizamos cámaras externas para localizar objetos,
que nos permiten enfocar nuestros esfuerzos
en el rápido desarrollo de las tareas altamente dinámicas.
Para las demostraciones de hoy,
usaremos tecnologías de localización nuevas desarrolladas por Verity Studios,
una escisión de nuestro laboratorio.
No hay cámaras externas.
Cada máquina de vuelo con sensores a bordo para determinar su ubicación en el espacio
ya cómputo de abordo para determinar cuáles deben ser sus acciones.
Los únicos comandos externos son los de alto nivel
como "despegue" y "tierra".
Esta es una llamada "tail-sitter".
Es un avión que intenta tener su pastel y comérselo.
Como otros aviones de ala fija, es eficiente en vuelo hacia adelante,
mucho más que los helicópteros y variaciones de los mismos.
A diferencia de la mayoría de aeronaves de ala fija,
es capaz de vuelo estacionario,
que tiene enormes ventajas para el despegue, aterrizaje
y versatilidad general.
No hay almuerzo gratis, por desgracia.
Una de las limitaciones con "tal-sitters"
es que son susceptibles a perturbaciones como ráfagas de viento.
Estamos desarrollando arquitecturas de control y algoritmos
para enfrentar esta limitación.
La idea es que la aeronave se recupere
no importa en qué estado se encuentre,
y con la práctica, mejore su rendimiento en el tiempo.
(Aplausos)
Bien.
Al hacer investigación,
a menudo nos hacemos preguntas abstractas fundamentales
que tratan de llegar al corazón de la cuestión.
Por ejemplo, una cuestión de este tipo sería,
¿cuál es el número mínimo de piezas móviles para el vuelo controlado?
Ahora, hay razones prácticas
por las que se desea saber la respuesta a esta pregunta.
Helicópteros, por ejemplo,
cariñosamente conocidas como máquinas con un millar de piezas móviles
todas conspirando para hacerte daño corporal.
Resulta que hace décadas,
pilotos cualificados podían pilotar aviones por control remoto
con solo 2 partes móviles:
una hélice y un timón de cola.
Recientemente hemos descubierto que se podía hacer con una sola.
Este es el "monospinner",
la máquina voladora controlable mecánicamente más simple del mundo,
inventada hace tan solo unos meses.
Tiene una sola parte móvil, una hélice.
No tiene aletas, sin bisagras, no hay alerones,
no hay otros actuadores, no hay otras superficies de control,
solo una hélice simple.
A pesar de que es mecánicamente simple,
se hace mucho en su pequeño cerebro electrónico
para volar establemente y moverse en cualquier lugar que quiera en el espacio.
Aun así, todavía no tiene
los algoritmos sofisticados del "tail-sitter",
lo que significa que para que vuele,
tengo que tirarlo a la perfección.
Y dada la probabilidad de que lo lance bien es muy baja,
dado que todo el mundo me mira,
lo que vamos a hacer en cambio
es mostrar un vídeo que rodamos ayer por la noche.
(Risas)
(Aplausos)
Si el "monospinner" es un ejercicio de austeridad,
esta máquina aquí, el "omnicopter", con sus ocho hélices,
es un ejercicio de exceso.
¿Qué se puede hacer con todo este excedente?
Lo que hay que notar es que es muy simétrico.
Como resultado, es ambivalente a la orientación.
Esto le da una capacidad extraordinaria.
Puede desplazarse a cualquier lugar
independientemente del lugar que enfrente
e incluso de la forma en que gire.
Tiene sus propias complejidades,
principalmente con los flujos que interactúan
de sus ocho hélices.
Algo puede modelarse, mientras que el resto se puede aprender sobre la marcha.
Vamos a ver.
(Aplausos)
Si los drones van a entrar en nuestra vida cotidiana,
tendrán que llegar a ser extremadamente seguros y fiables.
Esta máquina aquí
es en realidad 2 máquinas voladoras de dos hélices separadas.
Esta quiere girar en sentido horario.
Esta otro quiere girar en sentido antihorario.
Cuando se ponen juntas,
se comportan como un cuadrocóptero de alto rendimiento.
Si algo va mal, sin embargo,
--un motor falla, una hélice falla, la electrónica, incluso unas baterías--
la máquina todavía puede volar, aunque de forma degradada.
Vamos a demostrárselo ahora con la desactivación de una de sus mitades.
(Aplausos)
Esta última demostración
es una exploración de enjambres sintéticos.
El gran número de entidades autónomas, coordinados
ofrece una nueva paleta para la expresión estética.
Hemos tomado microcuadricópteros disponibles en el mercado,
con un peso de menos de una rebanada de pan,
y equipados con nuestra tecnología de localización
y algoritmos personalizados.
Como cada unidad sabe dónde está en el espacio
y es autocontrolada,
en realidad no hay límite a su número.
(Aplausos)
Ojalá estas manifestaciones los motiven a soñar
nuevas funciones revolucionarias para drones.
Ese ultra seguro de allí, por ejemplo,
tiene aspiraciones de convertirse en una pantalla volador en Broadway.
(Risas)
La realidad es que es difícil de predecir
el impacto de la tecnología incipiente.
Para gente como nosotros, la recompensa verdadera es el viaje y el acto creativo.
Es un recordatorio continuo
del maravilloso y mágico universo en el que vivimos,
que permite a las criaturas inteligentes, creativas,
esculpir de una manera tan espectacular.
El hecho de que esta tecnología
tiene tan enorme potencial comercial y económico
es solo la guinda del pastel.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)